aber kann
an alle meine nachbarn die dieses video
irgendwann sehen sollten tut mir leid
dass ich so schreib mir leid dass ich
wieder geschrieben hab aber hallo
willkommen zu den mai kreft commands
heute hier am freitag ja freunde sie
kommen bald pünktlich eigentlich kam sie
bisher immer pünktlich oder jedenfalls
ist es gerade relativ früh am morgen die
sonne scheint aber schon ich muss
vergleich noch zu uni hassel naber das
natürlich noch problem für den boards
ich habe wieder drei coole commands
vorbereitet die mir zu gesendet wurden
die ich gefunden habe die ich gut finde
und so weiter und so fort
das sieht sehr schön dass mit dem shader
weil immer wenn man in der nähe von
solar ist und so seht ihr diese punkte
unten links und ja ich würde mich freuen
wenn wir bis zum ende dran bleibt und
wir fangen direkt an mit command nummer
wir geben uns erstmal mit / gif tiff
format unterstrich blog das wichtigste
dieser serie einen command block dann
nehme ich mir dazu noch einen hebel und
ich füge dort diesen command ein und
dieser command spot erstmal einen
rüstungs ständer mit einem block dringt
man sich erklärt machen
als soldat hat gucken diese kühe dann
also das ist nur um euch zu zeigen wie
man beispiel hatte ja mal irgendwann
gezeigt dass man so blöcke einfach in
den boden spannen lassen kann oder wie
ein blog auf dem boden liegen kann
das funktioniert alles über die rüstung
stände und diese funktion natürlich kann
man da noch invisible reinpacken und
wird plötzlich alles damit der rüstung
ständer nicht zu sehen ist aber so
einfach mal damit ihr wisst wie es
funktioniert und zwar kann ich jetzt
auch mal hier neben noch einen befehl
blog stellen und diesen befehl wieder
eingeben und jetzt mal die zahlen
verändern zum beispiel packe ich jetzt
überall noch eine null hier rein
hier mache ich mal die null weg einfach
und hier mache ich mir auch die null weg
und aber immer nur einzelne
beispielsweise dann drücke ich hier mal
drauf und dann seht ihr schon ist der
einer ganz anderen stelle also nicht
komplett anders aber man sieht denke ich
schon dass die blöcke zum beispiel hier
unten ist gar nix hier und ist da der
blog also damit kann man das quasi
komplett variieren und das ermöglicht
komplett neue möglichkeiten denke
versteht was ich meine also es gab ja
teilweise diese sache mit diesen ringen
in minecraft was ihr euch vorgestellt
hatte das ist beispielsweise auch damit
gemacht werden wir sind zwar sehr fest
und ständer die da irgendwo dann
gesperrt und dann hängt man diese
blockade in verschiedenen richtungen
halt auch beispielsweise wir das hatten
wo blöcke auf dem boden lagen damit kann
man halt so viele sachen machen oder
dieser sitz oder so dann hat er diesen
dieses dingen daran dieses diese falltür
oder so und dann sieht deshalb aus wien
sitzt damit kann man diese ganzen sachen
machen ist sehr sehr cool ist der erste
command der wurde mir von jemand in die
kommentare geschrieben der allerdings
seinen echten namen dazu geschrieben hat
also seinen wirklichen namen deswegen
als nicht ob ich das den sagen soll
deswegen sage ich einfach mal danke an
dich personen die mir den geschickt hat
ja was wäre eine commands folge ohne ein
command von minecraft wahrscheinlich
erstmal noch eine command folge aber
einfach ohne dann was habe ich
eigentlich nicht schon wieder von
scheiße ist einfach wieder viel zu früh
am morgen sorgt ich gebe diesen befehl
erst wieder sehr sehr lange ihr seht es
ruckelt kurz ich drücke drauf und es
bald eine maschine in der zeit wo dies
pont erkläre ich euch mal ganz kurz
passt dieser jahns schon fertig ich sage
mal ganz grob helme die was können es
ist seine trails vanilla mod ich sag mal
mord einfach wandel am ort weil es
einfach mit einem command ist hier
kommen bei minecraft danke an dich wenn
du das video sieht sich denken wie es
dieses video sehen hier christian dich
findet sie immer alles in der
beschreibung also links roman von wem
die musik alles einfach jetzt gerade
darauf gerückt und bekomme ich ganz
viele helme und ich gehe jetzt bei order
kommt ein zombie das ist natürlich schon
mal nicht so geil aber ich gehe jetzt
mal eben hier nach da hinten fliegt
dabei eben hin und versetzte mich mal
eben in den game mode 0
damit ihr auch sehen dass das ganze in
game otten umfunktioniert und setzt
letztlich mir mal beispielsweise den
fire trailer auf wie ihr seht schon hin
was passiert denn ich gehe 5 und ihr
seht wenn ich rumlaufe kommt zur feuer
hinter mir her wenn ich stehe sieht es
dann quasi so aus als welches an
monstern wird mich grad verwandeln
irgendwie bei dragon ball oder so keine
ahnung ich habe dragon ball nicht
geschaut aber sieht das dann nicht auch
so aus wenn da irgendwas passiert und
hält irgendwie so ich weiß nicht aber
ich warte mal so der digimon pokémon
youtube und dragonball habe ich jetzt
natürlich ab und zu wenn sie wahr weil
es nicht die story waffe aber kein
ausländer mich dann was ist das denn für
eine scheiße
das kommt nicht vom hellen das kommt von
diesem feuer da vorne
das macht einfach über auf mich was ist
denn da für eine scheiße du mir nicht
gut
dann mache ich mir über den speed rail
darauf dass schon schnelligkeit und
sättigung also ich kann ihr laufen ohne
dass hier irgendwie
ihr hunger bald abgezogen werden dann
ist hier noch der sowohl das euch den
trailer der ist ein bisschen komisch ich
laut wird über mir fallen pfeil runter
nicht direkt über mir weil sonst
willicher sterben aber denke ihr wisst
was dieser helm macht dann haben wir
noch den wind trail der ist auch ganz
cool und zwar kann ich damit einfach
fliegen also ich könnte jetzt zu in die
luft laufen deswegen bin ich ein game
und null gegangen
wenn ich mir da ein bisschen zeit lassen
oder halt einfach sneaker oder irgendwie
sowas dann gehe ich nach zeit wieder
runter aber hiermit kann nicht quasi
einfach so durch die luft laufen auch
sehr sehr cool gemacht also wenn ihr das
hier so seht da zieht sondern spur
hinter mir her und kann damit quasi
durch luft laufen wenn ich mir den herrn
wieder absätze fall ich natürlich runter
und bin dementsprechend dann jetzt
gerade bei nicht so viel herz mehr
ich mache es einfach mal damit ihr das
seht hier so fort der charity es trenc
stray muss ich glaube ich nicht zeigen
das ist halt einfach mit stärke das ist
dann stärke habe dann haben wir hier die
flamme die ist einfach quasi immer um
mich rum also das ist also eine mischung
aus wind und feuer ist halt immer um
mich rum und ja das ist halt das dann
haben wir hier noch zwei andere meine
ich noch nicht vorgestellt hatte doch
drei anderen zwar der resource trail der
ist ganz nah fall nämlich einfach
ressourcen runter hat man quasi
unendlich ressourcen immer wo man
hinsieht fallen ressourcen oder und ich
kann die nachher sogar einsammeln
dann haben wir hier noch beispielsweise
ich sitzen wir wieder ab dann haben wir
noch den music trail das ist so dass
dann musik abgespielt wird glaube ich da
hat man die musik
wenn ich laufe und dann naja war aber
auch recht gut gemacht dann haben wir
den trail das ist somit einer der
coolsten da kann ich nämlich einfach
laufen und ihr seht schon hinter mir
sind tnt es die angezündet sind
explodieren die auch noch mal
explodieren ich habe ich die tnt hinter
mir her und es sieht sehr cool aus okay
dass sie ich dachte ich explodiere ich
bei dir noch aber das wäre auch da würde
ich mich ja selbst einfach mit in die
luft sprengt das ist auf jeden fall
nummer zwei wir sind wieder über acht
minuten ich muss in sieben minuten in
der uni seien aber immer noch 1,3 roman
nummer drei ist wieder eine mega coole
sache und zwar gehe ich dafür einfach
mal hier in die luft baue mich hoch und
eigentlich müsste man für diesen command
neue welt erschaffen wo man dann halt
bei flachland eingibt dass da einfach
anstatt erde dann er ist also anstatt er
anstatt dort muss man dann
beispielsweise einfach einschreiben
damit man der luft hat und zwar braucht
man dafür ein bisschen luft halt einfach
und das ist denke ich etwas was ihr auch
schon immer gesehen habe und zwar ist es
sky block mit einem command erschaffen
dass sie ist der befehl den gebe ich so
ein
der ist nicht so lang aber schon recht
lang also denke ich denke dass ich da
meine wurde zugesendet von marc m
das ist nämlich das auch gemacht habe
und zwar wirklich skywalk mit einem
command und wenn ich jetzt hier einfach
mal drauf drücken sie schon da es waren
diesmal recht viel und es geht jetzt
relativ schnell und wir haben hier
freunde wir haben hier wirklich gerade
einfach mit diesem kleinen command blog
sky blog erschaffen mit items nun mit
allen möglichen das ist sehr sehr geil
nach vorne geht doch schon symbolisch
die sonne gerade unter also hier kann
man hat quasi sky block spielen mit so
ein paar items die man halt da drin hat
man beispielsweise eine kuh die man
erschaffen kann man hat verschiedene
kern man hat auch verschiedene sand
arten um die sich beispielsweise glas zu
machen oder sowas in der richtung lover
ozelot obsidian für nette portal alles
mögliche hat man damit am start
das ist sehr sehr geil man müsste halt
quasi nur noch dann was ich jetzt gerade
nicht gemacht hat weil ich nicht so viel
zeit habe man müsste sich eine neue welt
machen flachland und da dann einfach
quasi das ding sind packen also einfach
luft anstatt erde und dann kann man sich
ganz einfach minecraft sky blanc quasi
mit einem command machen da muss man gar
nicht irgendwie sich was runterladen und
was weiß ich und heidi teil und
blablabla aber das ist es quasi das ist
der dritte command find ich mega cool
dass so was möglich ist finde ich
richtig geil habe ich mehr respekt vor
allgemein vor allen leuten
was machen wenn ihr ihnen den coolen
command irgendwo gesehen habt schreibt
mir die kommentare ich stelle ihn vor
mir gefällt diese serie sehr sehr gut
mir macht spaß euch das jeden fall da
vorzustellen dienstag kommt dann
wahrscheinlich wieder nur ein kleiner
command weil ich immer gesagt dienstags
haben aus unseren command allein ist ein
umfangreicher ist dahin gesund ich nicht
in die vollen gehen möchte und sonst
wäre ich mich freuen wenn ihr das video
mit einer positiven bewertung bewährte
wir sehen uns wir sehen uns jetzt gerade
weil man sieht sich immer zweimal und
was habe ich und tschüss